ce n'est pas un match comptant pour le
tournoi des six nations qui s'est
disputée l'autre jour à tour mais quand
les étudiants en médecine et en
pharmacie décide de s'affronter au rugby
cela est devenu une tradition en fait
joyeusement l'événement c'est ainsi que
joueurs et supporteurs se sont rendus en
cortège bruyant et coloré de leur
restaurant universitaire au stade
tonnelle
c'est la sixième fois que ce match avait
lieu les médecins étant donné comme
favori ayant apporté la coupe quatre
fois sur ce seul professeur nivière qui
donne le coup d'envoi de ce match qui
comme vous pourrez le constater a été
presque aussi disputée que france
angleterre
chaque péripétie de la rencontre était
orchestrée par les fanfares de la fal up
et des beaux-arts à la mi temps rien
n'est encore acquis les deux équipes
sont à égalité froid partout médecine
affirmera sa supériorité dans la seconde
mi-temps en battant pharmacie pour la
cinquième fois par 9 à 3